the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
oh right are you guys excited about
battlecode I'm so excited to service it
yeah yeah let's you're like a like a
hurray no no like again are you excited
yeah right that was such a strong yeah I
I know I actually mean that I have a
strange thing where when I say something
out like I'm meant the opposite of what
I said like I didn't believe it like
that time the true Houston from Dropbox
he's at Dropbox CEO he was like did you
guys remember this like he was at the he
was giving his sponsor talk at the
finals of battlecode last year and and
he was you know he was just wrapping up
and everybody was applauding and I came
to the podium and I was like thanks
thanks true that um that was really good
i I really if I didn't all that made me
want to work at Dropbox if I didn't have
a draw job already I would I would and
nobody believed me they thought I was
just like being facetious
so that dower that he hates me that was
that's maybe bad that happens to me um
okay let's uh let's get started soon so
you're all here because you're
interested in battlecode of these
lectures are optional they're geared at
like beginner to mid-level coders but
they'll be relevant even if you've had
coding experience in a million languages
because we're going to be talking a lot
of the time about battlecode the game
itself and it could just be a way to
keep yourself up to date on the latest
meta game for example so we're going to
go over the specs today I'm going to
introduce the competition and then after
lecture today we'll be having a lab
during which we'll help you set up so I
see a lot of you brought your computers
that's fantastic and that's also great
because it means if you get bored you
can just watch youtube videos yeah so
make sure to bring your earplugs so that
you don't bother the guy next to you
because he's already heard Gangnam style
alright so you know be a you know
respectful of those guys so here's our
here's our introduction my name is
Maxwell man
I'll be your lecturer for the next 10
days it actually is -4 days because of
various things so it's like the next two
weeks you can come here at this time or
slightly earlier so that you can hear a
lousy joke you can come here and you can
hear me talk about the game and hear
what the devs think about what you might
need to know and then you can eat food
at 6 p.m. when we have massive
quantities of food coming and then from
6 to 7 you have the option of staying
for the lab session which has been
described in anticipation as a social
utopia and you know that I really
believe that it could be one because
everybody here has sort of some similar
interests so to introduce us we
developers our students or alums who
have worked on developing battlecode I'm
Max sitting here in the front is an
Epstein and Steven Valdez you'll be
using them for help all the time if you
need it or just to bother them because
you feel like it
they're here for no other reason and you
know to maintain the codebase and these
kinds of things the website is
battlecode org and we have a forum there
where you can also go to get help and I
also particularly would like to direct
your attention to the IRC Channel it's
pound battlecode on freenode so I don't
know if you know what that is but it's
basically a way that you can talk to us
on a real-time chat so you can do that
at pretty much any hour than any hour of
the day because the way we're setting it
up this year is we'll all be available
of you know pretty much the whole time
ok make sure that if you are an MIT
student and you want credit for this
class it's a six credit class you can
you just have to sign up on websites for
six point s 187 how many people have
signed up on web sis already alright
that's like everybody let's talk about
the goals of the competition what is you
know what is a game what do we
doing I'm sure a lot of you were
thinking all right well here we go got a
I've got finals tomorrow but I have to
decide what IP classes to take gosh this
is a terrible combination of deadlines
then you thought oh should I take chai
do battle code should I do like one of
these other things like like web
programming or GamePro what is the you
know operating system watch Madhu's it's
you should I should I do this or that
and you're probably thinking to yourself
what is you know what is fun what is
valuable for me what am I going to learn
and we asked ourselves the same question
you know a couple months before then was
you know what do we want the battlecode
competition to be like and what we ended
up deciding was that the game needs to
be fun and it needs to contain classic
battle code areas of challenge for in
artificial intelligence so this is a
game that is a cross we've always said
in the past that it's not Starcraft but
it is a cross between a real-time
strategy game and an AI programming
competition so what we wanted was the
game to be easy to learn but hard to
master so what you'll see when I
describe the game specs and I'm going
into it just in just momentarily when I
describe the game specs is you'll see
ways to play the game and then ways to
excel at the game so it's like you've
got this infinite ramp that you can you
know run wild on of how much effort you
want to put into developing the best
player or better yet you know because
what is the best is comparative that's
comparing to somebody else but that's
kind of irrelevant what you want is to
have fun anyway you know that
so the yeah so there we go our idea was
to not have sort of skill caps and
limiting factors like like maps that are
just covered in maze so you can't do
anything unless you can get past that
maze like okay you didn't you didn't
pass the test I hope you enjoy your
starting area no no's
so not that so let me uh let me show the
game not how many of you have seen
battle code before show of hands so
that's a good number but it's not
everybody so I'm going to show you a
game so this is a when you've made your
and you've put it into the client you
can run a game like this and we'll go
over how to do that and I'll just hit
play here and you'll see the red team in
the upper left and the blue team in the
bottom right playing a game of battle
code for this year the player on the
upper left in red is placing mines and
capturing bases his soldiers are moving
around and fighting with one another
with fighting the enemy hopefully and
the blue player here at the bottom right
is just sort of shooting his guys off to
die at the enemy army on the left you
know you'll see indicators of various
game constants and values that are
changing if I pause this for a second
you can see by clicking on any robot you
can see his his ID number what robot
type it is you can see his hit point
level which we have characteristically
had a very difficult to remember name
for we always have different names for
their energy and their hit points this
year it's going to be Energon for hit
points you can see I think this flux
number is actually no longer relevant
and you can ignore it
see we we work so hard on making this
polished and perfect that we weren't
finished until actually we're not
finished yet they're still fussing with
something the byte codes used is going
to be a key factor that you're going to
look at so that you can determine how
much computational energy those robots
are spending this year there's a very
big impact on the efficiency of your
code and the performance of your player
if you have efficient code you can have
twice as many robots on the field then
if then you can sustain if your code is
inefficient because the because the
actual computational cost is recorded
and is then implemented into the upkeep
of each unit finally you'll see the
location of the unit and three indicator
strings that you can use for debugging
and control purposes so what we'll do
today is talk about what kinds of things
are on this map and how that's different
and amazingly great and how this year's
new gameplay will be even more fun than
it ever has been and I can say that with
some confident confidence because it's
quite different and demonstrably better
yes
so what we think of as skill areas areas
that make a fun game for battlecode are
navigation but not that you so much
require it see in this example you they
didn't really need any complex maze
solving algorithms what they were just
doing is you know there are these
neutral minds that are here and you
could either walk around the neutral
minefield or you could just clear
yourself right on through it so there's
navigation but you don't necessarily
have to do it there's there's group
pathing and that's that's a good point
because you know okay you anybody can
take one unit and after enough time
figure out how to implement any of the
existing pathing algorithms but let's
say you've got multiple units you know
they start to get in one another's way
let me given it let me give an example
that's very concrete and it hits really
close to home for me because I did this
all the time I've done battle code I
guess like for years now and and so what
I'd always have is I'm here and I want
to go to
- ice cream it was something desirable
and I'm trying to get past this wall so
I go here but then all my friends take
up all this space because they're going
the same way and then I'm starting to
I'm trying to turn around and go back
and they're trying to go this way
because they think it's closer to the
ice cream and we just we just end up
here all day and then the enemy comes by
and shoots us and then you know we've
got holes in ourselves how are we going
to maintain that stomach area to keep
the ice cream in it's just not going to
work so we like navigation we like group
padding we like messaging this year the
messaging system is totally new in the
past what you need is I'm going to go
back to the screen here is your robot
would only be able to see a certain area
around himself and so every other robot
would not know what's going on on the
whole map except by messaging but even
then they would have to receive messages
that are broadcast within a certain
range so you'd end up having to make
these chains where you'd say all right
I've got let's see Joe and James and a
jalopy they're all in line and you know
these three robots are in line and they
each have some some broadcast radius and
so maybe I can sort of set up a relay
chain and they're broadcasting back and
that was how you used to communicate
information about where the enemy is so
here's the here's the ice cream here and
here's me and I would have to you know
hear it from these four guys but it
would end up you know that would end up
being like a lot of work for me to
implement and that that we like that we
think that that's really cool but at the
same time it ended up meaning that if
the ice cream were an enemy and I needed
to Scout that the enemy were coming with
some rush that what would often happen
is that the enemy would is that there
wouldn't be a chain established because
you know this kind of stuff is kind of
hard to do so this guy would see the
enemy right here and here's me back here
I'm just minding my own business maybe
I'm building a staircase which we did in
one year or some other very useful
expenditure of effort and time so this
guy sees the enemy and I don't know
about it I can't prepare until he comes
back
okay so then he
back to within broadcast range he's here
but by then the enemy's right there I
can't do anything so the reasons what
we've done this year is we've said all
right
realistically we've got these radios
right let's communicate on these radios
across the whole map so now your radio
messages can be heard across the whole
map but instead of being messages like
they used to be and these messages were
kind of annoying there were these
constructs that you had to assemble
you'd say all making a new message and
I'm applying these parts to it and not
every message has every type of part and
not every part has every type of message
and every time I receive a message I can
receive an infinity of messages and then
my robot explodes because he's being
overloaded with messages don't like spam
it happens a lot happens to me so so
what we did instead is we said all right
we got a uniform message channel we've
got 10,000 channels and any robot can
post an integer to any one of those
channels at any time so then my robot
could be posting you know maybe my my
code is using frequency 567 and I'll be
communicating on that frequency
specifically where I'm going or what
direction I'm going or something like
that and everybody on my team can see it
so that's that's a really useful sort of
centralizing feature so if the enemy's
coming I can just look on integer number
567 and if the enemy is coming maybe
that's a flag maybe I make that like I
guess 666 because that's like really bad
right so I make that my token for enemy
is coming and then Bing everybody can
start preparing for the enemy coming but
there's more I mean let's say you're
you're going to metagame them you're
gonna you're going to think about what
could happen from a high level what when
would the enemy just invade when would
they attack me I mean I don't have to
see them coming to know that they will
for example maybe the map is really
small so this year you can tell how big
the map is I mean how does it make sense
this happened again and again in
previous years how does it make sense to
have a game where players are expected
to operate intelligently in the absence
of information okay I
understand that like sometimes a little
bit of uncertainty can be great like how
great would poker be if everybody knows
what everybody else's hand is like that
would be really lousy right but here we
just add almost no information so you'd
have build order losses this is sort of
a big problem in my in my eyes with
Starcraft which is that you know you
you'd start with a strategy that could
lose before you have any information on
how to fix that so you don't I mean at
least in StarCraft you know how big the
map is so here we've giving them the
following centralized information so
here's what I'll do I'm going to list
out the centralized information that you
can use that you didn't really use to
have access to now you might ask all
right all right
I see I'm not going to memorize this and
I'm not taking notes even though I did
bring a thingamabob er which is a
computer or a notebook I mean you might
say I'm not going to memorize this I'm
not interested I'm here to have fun well
look here you can look in the Java Docs
and you can see all of the robot
abilities they're listed in this giant
list here and you'll have time to peruse
those will sort of go over them over the
course of the few lectures but having
them sort of in a condensed form or
organized into topics like what is
centralized information you know what
information can I use ends up probably
being a bit of a convenience so I have a
couple of convenient organizations of
data and that's really all I'm here for
is just you know you can get all this
information in our documentation which
will supply you when we help you set up
the game or and or you can sort of hear
it from me
where I've got it sort of organized into
a slightly different way the centralized
info that you get includes you can sense
the positions of all allied robots so
there's a there's a function and again
we have very good naming conventions so
that all of the names that we pick let
you know exactly what we're referring to
and for what for this function we call
it
it's a method called sense nearby game
objects and that's great because it can
detect game objects across the map
anywhere they don't have to be nearby so
that's that's really nice and it senses
these things which of course you would
want a sense they're objects I you know
I was playing chess the other day with
with my friend Rick and I said to him
you know what I could I could use more
of his game objects we do I can I can
sense all of your game objects and he
didn't get it so the sense near got
nearby game objects is a is an
overloaded function which means that you
can you can call it with multiple
arguments and that really does help you
so the point is this is this is a global
function because you can see any any
game object if that game object is of a
certain type so all of your allied
robots you can see so let's say I let's
go back to our example let's say that I
am back here that's me
over here at the bottom and this guy up
at the top I can see where he is back
from here but my sight range is actually
only here so it's like I've got
different detection abilities so like
allied robots allied mines and neutral
mines are all visible no matter where
you are but enemy robots are only
visible within your sight radius so but
it's within any allied robot sight
radius it's harder to explain than it is
to think about in this picture this
robot can see these guys because he's
really close but this guy can also see
them because this robot is nearby right
does that that's pretty straightforward
one person was nodding but he was also
yawning so he may have been nodding off
now I'm only joking yeah the
in cents nearby gameobjects is like kind
of is a kind of useful thing to be able
to do but it's not always obvious how to
use it so later on I'll be talking about
how one of the inputs to this is what
type of game object you want cuz like I
still haven't been saying game object
over and over but none of you care about
game objects you care about like enemy
robots I want to shoot at the enemy
robots so you would end up writing oh I
want I want a robot please so you tell
it
give me game objects of type robot class
and you would say RA this is this is
getting kind of confusing I'm feeling a
little bit overwhelmed well don't you
worry about it because here in the Java
Docs under package and you might notice
that this is the this is the Java Docs
version seven for java version 7 so real
sleek we're distributing this at
absolutely no cost yeah the the let's
see here so I wanted let oh look it's
game object there it is
uh and what things are oh look sub
interfaces include encampments and
robots oh that's great that answers my
question so now I know that I can put
robot class or encampment class and it
will give me that type of game object
yeah yeah alright so that's a set that's
a piece of centralized information
another piece of centralized info so
we've talked about how its allied robots
we've got the the messaging sit over
there there's allied minds and I'll talk
about those the minds and how you how
you can lay them and defuse them and how
you you know how you get these how you
get these things onto the game board
allied robots allied Minds you've got
other the radio system which is entirely
global and that means that you can
disrupt somebody else's radios program I
have a hunch that there are several
people out there who
would broadcast random numbers to my
favorite channel 567 and it would just
totally ruin my player I wouldn't worry
able to work at all now in order to
limit this sort of you know there's sort
of a back and forth between sending
messages that you want to send receiving
the messages with a certain amount of
sort of redundancy in there so that you
can be safe against message jamming
versus actual jamming itself how do we
assess the balance of these two of these
competing objectives well we've got a
cost associated with everything you know
you there's no free lunch except dinner
for battlecode and that is actually free
we ordered so much pizza for today now
I'm sure I'm sure none of you have
ordered that not many of you ordered
that much pizza before but let me tell
you that I expected that there's like
120 people here in the room and I we
thought like how much pizza does
everybody eat well unfortunately no
battlecode is like a male-dominated
class so we'll have like slightly more
piece of consumption than otherwise is
that is that sexist and so so we decided
to get 50 pizzas and we're like well
what's awesome Pizza we like Bertucci's
you guys don't like / - cheese yeah he
likes verducci's yeah so so that was
like twenty dollars a pizza so it was
like a thousand dollars for pizza my
goodness well anyway it's gonna be
really good and it's and it's only and
it's coming in like a half an hour
that's right I totally lost my train of
thought right I was yeah I was saying
that not that there's no free lunch and
as such we have a bytecode cost now I
think in the past has not been that
obvious to me what the cost of doing a
certain computation is you know can I
jam the enemy is that really going to
work or am I going to run out of money
is a question you could ask so here in
the let's see here I have a place where
I have installed battle code and you're
gonna do something just like this where
you'll have battle code that's okay he
had to go to the bathroom don't don't
worry about him well it's a reasonable
supposition he is human isn't he all
right and so here in the battle code
directory where I've installed battle
code there's going to be a text file
that's called method costs bingo
all right now looks disorganized because
everything in the strings of different
lengths but each string represents a
function that you can use like like for
example a tax square or maybe broadcast
a message ah that was the one we were
interested in okay let's look at that
broadcast cost 25 byte codes all right
let's do a little bit of math arithmetic
it's not math is it 25 byte codes all
right there are 10,000 strings which I
wrote and erased to ten thousand places
to write a message to there are 25 byte
codes to broadcast a message okay so
that means that I can broadcast 400
messages is that right is that this
number divided by that number equals
that number is that yeah yeah yeah let's
go with it yeah let's go with that so
you have 400 but that's no but maybe
most maybe you have more of your robot
jamming signals okay how many robots can
you have alright let's let's do that
let's do that computation I'm pretending
that I'm you and that I'm just like okay
okay I'm not doing a very good
impersonation
I recognize that you'll be much faster
at this so you would want to find out
how many robots you can sustain can I
get somebody to suggest one way to
figure out that number yes you you you
uh yes um I you could you could make a
player and just spawn robots until they
start dying let's say you wanted to do
it in a different way I have the example
here where I have what is it but the
game constants there we are so here I'm
looking at the javadocs
and I can click on game constants
and and I'm looking at a different
version of it that didn't actually show
the game constants in the game constants
page but that's because we are well
organized and you know this is to show
that we're indomitable indefatigable as
it were these constant values indicate
here that your that your headquarters is
capable of producing a quite a few
resources
this shows that it produces 50 resources
per turn
now this resource production enables you
to have an upkeep of robots so in the
past we've had names like flux and so on
this year the name for it is power so
we've got and if that's tough though
because we have time as well and as you
well know power times time is energy and
so now we have n argonne and energy
which is a multiple or a calculated
quantity from power but don't you worry
too much about it it's just a number and
the usage of of this resource or power
by robots is is is displayed in unit
upkeep which here is written incorrectly
I'm going to bring up the most recent
version of this document what's nice is
that you guys will get one version and
then you'll have one version on your
computer and not like 16 and they'll all
and your one version will be up-to-date
and when you want to update it the
client will automatically tell you that
it needs updating so you'll just have
the one version and you won't have
disaster area yeah constant values so
this is the more recently updated one
and you can see here the unit power
upkeep is one all right fantastic we're
ready to do a computation so I'm going
to put here 40 divided by so this is the
amount of energy or the amount of power
that's produced per turn by your
headquarters divided by the usage of
that power now you're going to say all
right I'm bored this is all this is I
can I can do this in my head
well maybe you can but some of us can't
all right no so that would be the number
but that would say that the number of
robots you get is independent of how
much work they're doing and that doesn't
make any sense
you should get to have more robots if
you're doing less computation so here
you can see there is a cost power cost
per byte code which is here and it's 10
to the minus 4 so let's say that I'm
using 10 so 10 to the minus 4 times the
number of byte codes well if I'm using
zero byte codes then I get 40 because
that would be 1 plus 0 and 40 over 1 is
okay and if I were using 10,000 which is
also known as 10 to the 4 then I would
get 20 wow what a big difference so that
tells you that if you want to go ahead
and spam the message system let's say
you're spamming so you're using all of
your byte codes possible and you have 20
robots so 20 robots are spamming 400
message integers per turn
so you're doing nothing but spamming the
messages and you're getting eight zero
zero zero uh yah ah oh it's not even
enough it's not enough ah well so that
shows that you could Jam the enemy and
maybe you should you know if you've got
nothing better to do if you derive a
personal satisfaction from it and you
know but this is worth saying these
kinds of calculations are important for
strategy but don't don't make them
totally fixed in stone because we change
the game just we tweak it a little bit
for balance so if it ends up being that
10,000 is just so much radio space that
we just would rather not have it then it
could just get knocked down to 1,000 and
then all of a sudden your player which
depends on this or that messaging
construct may have to be you know
somewhat we thought so this is a good
time to talk about the organization of
the competition is it is it I think it
is
the the let's go to the battlecode
website and let me show you something I
don't know if you knew that you could do
this but previously reavie Aesir is
we've had like a list and it'll be in
text form and it'll say on this date we
have you know this competition and this
one.we event and then you have to open
up a window of this and then every
single one of you opens up another
window with Gmail or Google Calendar and
then you like manually enter in do you
not do that who like has to do that
whenever you have like a competition you
want to know when things are yeah yeah
there's like two people who also have to
do that so I figured in light of saving
those two people some effort we made
this Google Calendar and you can see
here's here's today's classroom session
here in one one ninety from 5:00 to 6:00
p.m. and it's got into the lab written
there so the specs and software are
released like as of thirty seven minutes
ago roughly speaking and what we'll do
after this is we'll talk about how to
set it up so there you go specs and
software released the Sprint tournament
is on the fourteenth and what that means
is you can submit a player for that and
you can be entered for a relatively
small prize pool like a relatively small
the actual the prize pool for the finals
is I think fifty thousand dollars so
relatively small it's just like some
fraction of that which is still not
negligible I don't know I don't know it
would probably anyway so that's going to
be really exciting because that will
give you the opportunity to test your
code out to see what other players are
doing because to some extent you know
winning is going to is going to be
related to what other people do but more
importantly having fun is related to
what other people do and talking to the
other people like this social utopia of
mine the idea of this lab is totally new
as well as the Google Calendar to try to
make things more easy and fun and you
know and and together among among us as
battle coders because we do all share
that common link yes so the the the
point is that if you didn't know that
you could do this what you do is you go
to if you want to add this to your own
calendar there's like a button where you
where you can go and do that and I think
my I think the
isn't available because I yeah they're
there at the bottom at the bottom yeah
there you go
and then you just add it right in so
I've already got it here in my personal
calendar and there you go there you go
so you can see that I'm having lunch on
the 24th and you can okay so you get you
get the idea so the Sprint tournament is
the submission deadline you can see here
is on the 14th on the 16th on that
Wednesday is in class will show some of
the games from the Sprint tournament
I don't think we'll show all of them see
because what used to happen is we would
show all the games and there's like a
hundred teams and that ends up being a
relatively large size you know
round-robin bracket with I think double
elimination so it's like a ton of games
I think it generally takes like five
hours but it ends up bumping up to six
seven or eight hours because it's like
we end up showing up there and the
tournament code that sets it all up
doesn't work and so it's like takes
forever so what we're going to do this
year is we'll just sort of distill it
down we'll have something simple to show
that's like a fantastic and exciting on
the Wednesday and in the future when we
have our later our seeding tournaments
which is sort of the same the same kind
of thing but it's more important because
it determines your positioning for the
final tournament when we have this
seeding tournament we're going to
livestream it on the internet so that
you don't even have to I mean you guys
all trekked out here in the dead of
night at 5:00 or 6:00 p.m. you know in
the in the freezing cold you might have
I mean there could be people out there
dying because they came they've tried to
make it here and they didn't make it
that would be horrible that's not
something to laugh at yeah yeah so so
you came all the way out here but we
don't want to make you have to do that
much work because we want you to have
fun so there you go we've got a calendar
to save you that effort we have lab
sessions to save you the effort of
trying to make friends and we and we'll
have live streams in the future which
will make that much better
so as you can see here it says the
seeding tournament submission deadline
is on the 21st and the seeding
tournament will be on the 22nd so what
that does is it gets you your position
in the finals tournament the final
submission deadline is different though
so you can continually update your
player my point is that you only have
three weeks it's
vii today and the final submission
deadline is 228 you have three weeks to
make an amazing player and each week
you'll have the chance to you know you
could upload your player at any time you
can do scrimmage matches with other
players at any time and then you know
finally you'll be able to submit to the
finals I mean I don't think it's worth
getting you know too hyped up about this
final thing because after all in my
experience you know game changes at the
last minute screw you over at the finals
and it ends up being a crapshoot no no
IIIi exaggerated but the point is the
fun should be had as you go and I am
here to help with that so the what you
need so just one more thing about this
administration is that if you want to i
think it's required that you upload a
resume and that you be an MIT student if
you want to earn no that's not right we
have international competitors this year
we're at we have like sort of a thing
going on with the University of Sussex
if you have friends at other
universities they can feel free to join
you and they don't have to be MIT
students to either play or win money and
if they're if they're in Honolulu or you
know Alaska we'll fly them in here for
the finals because we expect the
finalists to show up at this like dinner
that we have at the Hyatt we have this
like fantastically lavish dinner that's
like I think we paid like five thousand
dollars for it where where the sponsors
Aaron could you come up here and show
what the sponsors are by just like
having you turning your back to the
audience no I actually there's a button
here I can do that yeah yeah that's a
good point okay so here are our sponsors
we have these like fancy company reps
show up at this dinner so if you're if
you're among the finalists then you show
up at the at the fancy reps dinner and
they like offer your jobs and stuff it's
apparently very nice I've never been
yeah that's because I was busy yeah
that's why yeah that's why that's right
no so these are these are some of the
sponsors are our main sponsors and and
some other ones and you'll get a chance
to meet them as well at the finals so
you know you don't have to be the best
of the best by whatever stupid metric we
come up with what you have to be is you
know anybody who does battlecode is an
attractive person to these to these
employers who will meet you and like
give you business cards and it'll be a
good time for everyone and so that in
that note you have once again on the
calendar page the finals are on the 2nd
of February so that'll be that'll be
when that happens and it'll be in 26100
it'll be a blast and you should be
looking forward to that very much I feel
like I've just been droning on ranting
about what I don't like about Starcraft
and I haven't talked enough about the
things that are related to gameplay this
year this year you have these robots and
I'm gonna you know it's it's astounding
to me that I rent always that white
didn't work because I was using this one
instead of this one and are meant to use
them this main client yeah that's the
one okay okay yeah I'm gonna run I'm
gonna run this this was the point I was
trying to make earlier where I was going
to take compute time bots playing
against compute time bots on this map
this is your this is this is how this is
sort of how to do it but it'll be done a
little bit differently and so the goal
here is to see how many robots can be
built but this guy uh Iza I think I
think team a and B got switched so what
I'll do is I'll just I'll just briefly
switch around the code so this is sort
of the structure of a robot controller
what happens is this code is run on each
robot on your team and that's what plays
the game I'm sure most of you know that
already and so what I'll do is I'll just
check that the team is B so I can switch
switch the team hit save I run it again
and so well it doesn't work as well as I
was expect
because these guys are just dying when
they go through the minefield that's
interesting so then I guess what you
know you can make your own Maps in this
this is a really good example you know
debugging you can save that I did this
on purpose although if you have a strict
adherence to honesty you might not so
the maps are located where like you're
looking at you're looking at what here
so you'll have a directory where you can
see your maps and you'll be also able to
see them here so here's simple and what
if I want to edit this map you know can
I do that can I just double click it
it's an XML document
oh look is it
Oh sim oak data okay here's here's some
data I'm beginning to get to the part
see this would be really easy if I could
just do edit with like notepad news
source source no tab down down Oh bingo
alright yeah thank you so then you can
see that I can make my own maps using
these codes so the character 3 indicates
in neutral mind so I can just do like
find and replace where I'll replace 3
with period which is an open terrain
I'll just do replace all and then I'll
just make sure to change this one or
else the whole map would be mines
I'm sure two of you thought that I
wouldn't do that but I assure you that I
am operating at full capacity alright so
this is an example where you can see
I've just built a bunch of robots and
you can see that this is my power your
power is stored in a reserve bank and
what I'm going to do is suddenly at
around 1,000 is I'm going to start
computing a lot so right now you can see
that this robot is using 38 byte codes
not very many and if you if you have the
if you're amazing at counting you'll see
that there are about 40 here and the new
robots are boom look at that the new
robots die because they don't have
enough these guys don't have enough
compute they don't have enough power to
run so they lose hit points until
they're dead
and then if they all start using code
boom we cut down to half the number and
so you can see quite visually the effect
of using a thousand using ten thousand
byte codes versus using no byte codes at
all
so from here down to there bang these
are this power quantity can be affected
by various things so the there's there
are some equations I could show for what
for what that is but maybe I've just
gone a bit of far afield here because
I've been talking about some details
here's here's the general overview right
you don't really need too many of the
specifics because all you've got to do
is find the enemy and there's a function
that does that oh look at that I'll just
add that to the global list there's a
sense enemy headquarters bingo gun if
you were interested in a little bit of
masochism coding masochism and just
doing something the hard way you could
do that because what we've also provided
is the dimensions of the map and you
know that the upper left corner of the
map is zero zero so with a symmetry
operation you could say my headquarters
is here the map size is this my location
is here therefore the enemy must be at
this other location so more than one way
to skin a cat as the case may be
so you locate the enemy and all you have
to do is walk up to him because this
year attacking happens automatically for
soldiers so right right now there isn't
any fighting going on but I'll show an
example that will show that all they've
got to do is go near one another and
then their attack power is distributed
among all of the robots they can see so
this is a some old code that we were
writing when we were testing the game
and what you'll find is that when robots
come close to one another
they make these circles that indicate
which robots that indicate their attack
range so their attack this guy is
distributing his attack among this one
and that one similarly this one is
distributing among these three
so his attack power in this version of
the game was different but right now I
believe the attack power is six so he
would be dealing two damage to
to these what you also see in this
picture which I believe is quite
destructive is the shield robots so they
should yeah any robot that's standing
next to this shields robot will be given
this additional shields parameter and so
you can see it here in the in the user
interface there's a green bar indicating
health and a blue bar indicating shields
in the latest implementation of battle
code shields serve as a protection only
against a certain type of encampment
that can be built so these these
encampments work in the following way
the the robots the you start with just a
headquarters and that produces these
soldiers so you can produce a soldier at
any tile around you if that tile is
unoccupied that soldier can then be used
to construct an encampment and he can
instruct he can construct any of a
number of types of encampment so I've
made this nice handy useful battlecode
data sheet people from last year might
remember that I made sort of a handy
unit sheet at that time but this year
it's a hundred percent more accurate
than last year's that's right
we've checked and double-checked that
this is the latest version so you can
see here all of the different types of
units and there's a boolean for whether
it is an encampment in terms of just a
you know description although you know
that's kind of not a fantastic
description because all of these because
all of these units you know because we
like to be straightforward you know it's
a realistic preparation for your life as
a professional coder that the databases
and documentation you receive will
contain information opposite to the way
that things are run so you can see here
that they're all lists some of these are
listed as encampments but in fact they
are all robots yes if I believe that's
correct they are all robots so the the
headquarters is what you start with it
generates 40 power per turn and it can
spawn these soldiers it takes ten turns
to spawn a soldier or it can research
upgrades and I'll talk about the
upgrades below in just a minute the
soldier has an upkeep of one to two
power per turn depending on bytecode
usage it automatically distributes its
attack power among adjacent enemy units
and it has the capability of laying
mines which take 25 turns to lay a mine
defusing mines which take five turns and
capturing encampments which takes 50
turns now you might ask alright where am
I getting these numbers I'm assembling
this sort of convenient diagram but what
if the specs change you know where do I
get these numbers well they're all under
game constants under robot type enum or
the upgrade enum and you'll find them
all in the Java Docs alternatively you
can always ask us where they are by
going on our IRC chat or talking to one
of us in person so you can see here
they're laying mines defusing mines
capturing encampments and in the act of
capturing one of these encampments which
is a pre-existing location on the map
these black circles in the act of
capturing one of those and you know you
don't you don't this is there's nothing
magical about it because here among the
robot controller methods you'll find
capture encampment and what you'll do is
you'll specify what type of encampment
you want it to be and you might ask what
types are there well you could either
look at my handy chart or you could
click here under robot type and this
enum robot type will show you the types
that you can build you can build
artillery generator medbay
shields and supplier the headquarters
and soldier are you know different
they're not built from encampments I
don't know that that's written anywhere
but I've said it so now you know it yeah
the so that's how you're going to be
able to build these units that are shown
here so the the medbay heels adjacent
robots to hit points per turn and you
can see that's that's their quote attack
power because you know that's attack is
a lot like healing you know modern
surgery you can use scalpel and such
these are these are also considered
weapons I'm sure you couldn't bring a
scalpel on a plane so attack is a really
good word for a healing a healing unit
and and if you don't believe me
talk to any medicine man you know
Shields I will will give all adjacent
robots five shield points per turn so if
you cost her eight units around them
then that'll go ahead and give 40 shield
points distributed among them to the
extent that five times eight is forty
the the shields only protect you from
artillery though they don't protect you
against other robot other soldiers now
these robots that are shielded will lose
one shield point per turn as it wears
off but there's no cap on the amount of
shields they can have so they can have I
think ten to the eighth shields which is
like a lot more than their total hit
points of forty right so that's
effectively infinite the artillery is
the one unit that can shoot at a far
range it can shoot at a range of
sixty-three now we always talk about
squared ranges because that makes it
easier to do comparisons without having
to take a square root so he like s if we
did give you ranges and not squared
ranges you could just square it and then
compare it to the range that you had
just calculated but but this way this
way works really well so what I can do
is I can I can demonstrate for you what
that looks like by opening up oh my
goodness I'm almost out of time I can
open up this that stockpiling no that's
not right I made it in the in the
mapmaker program down here yeah so this
shows you what 63 looks like so if
you're here in the middle you can see
all of these tiles but you can't see the
ones outside every us but it's site
range is only 14 every every robot has a
site range of 14 as you can see here in
this document so the attack range is 63
the site range is 14 so this is one of
those cases where you need like scouting
units that would they would know what to
shoot at and it would be really and it's
really helpful that you have this global
information because you don't need to
post to radio to tell the artillery what
to shoot it because he can already see
all of the units that your
allies can see he can't necessarily see
the enemies unless your guys are nearby
so yes the artillery does 40 damage to
the target that it specifies and 20
splash damage to adjacent tiles and that
does include friendly fire so you got to
be careful about where you shoot the
generator generates ten resources per
turn and that's at that resources is
power so that's added on to your
headquarter power so if you build a
bunch of generators you can support more
soldiers and finally the supplier will
reduce the build time for soldiers by 5%
and that's multiplicative so that if you
have two suppliers then it's point nine
five squared times ten turns this year
we give you the opportunity of building
upgrades as well of researching upgrades
at your headquarters so your
headquarters is your central unit the
goal is to defeat the enemy headquarters
to do that you could just walk your
robots on over and kill them dead
there's it's not required that you
research upgrades or build encampments
that's one of the ways that we make the
competition somewhat easier to easier to
enter easier to get something that works
but if you want to research upgrades you
know you want to make a strategy that's
tailored around a certain approach then
you can get these the fusion upgrade
reduces your energy decay because the
the way that you hold power is that you
can't just mess it up indefinitely you
know you you get a power income from
your headquarters and you spend power to
upkeep your soldiers but we don't want
that you know if you have no soldiers
and you're just getting getting income
we don't want that to go up indefinitely
so every turn that gets multiplied by by
a number that reduces it so the energy
decay or the loss is 20% but if you
research fusion the loss is only 1% so
then you might think of stockpiling
energy and then spending it all at once
to get a larger burst of robots which
couldn't be sustained for a long time
but then again you only have to win for
one second
finally the okay so then there's there's
a more upgrades vision upgrade extends
your squared vision
10 to 32 they should say 14 but as you
know everything is always up-to-date a
hundred percent of the time so here's
here's a here's a demonstration of what
that would look like here's 10 and
here's 30 - boom on a big difference
that's quite as quite a lot more vision
that's important because you can diffuse
any mind within your sight range if you
have the diffusion ability which is not
to be confused with chemical diffusion
which is something else yes this is for
diffusing things and it is spelled
correctly so yeah what that extends your
mind defusing range that's pretty
important but keep in mind that you can
still only diffuse one at a time so you
your d few have to select which one
you're going to diffuse and then you
diffuse that now it's important to note
that you can see where I've said that
you see your allied Minds
I haven't said that you can see your
neutral minds as well but you don't see
enemy minds until one of your robots has
stepped on it so that means that you
can't you all I don't think you can even
I don't think you can diffuse something
you can't see but actually I don't know
I don't know we'll have to opt check
with that because it may be that you can
just spam diffuse on terrain that you
don't know and that that might actually
diffuse things that you can't see at the
same time that's not a fantastic
strategy because diffuse takes five
turns and during those five turns you
cannot attack so that leaves you or I
can you attack I think you might and
think you maybe you can attack but you
you know what you can't it's very
vulnerable position to be defusing
something because you know you're
concentrating on something else how are
you going to perform as effectively at a
different task pickaxe is the tool that
you really need if you want to lay a ton
of mines because instead of laying just
one mine where your robot is I guess I'm
going to come out have to come up with a
system for describing robot that's sort
of like a robot maybe it's a Chinese
character
so that's your robot and ordinarily he
would lay a mine here but if you have
pickaxe he will lay mines in all these
positions for the same cost of laying
just one mine pretty useful to have
so and it takes the same amount of time
so laying a mine cost 25 rounds
diffusing a mine cost 5 rounds so you
could do the math if you have pickaxe
you can lay them as fast as the other
team can defuse them provided you can
get into an open space where you can do
it realistically that you know they
might be able to encroach and and get
you during that time and why do you want
to lay mines you know isn't that doesn't
that slow the game down doesn't that
mean that things will just move move
slowly make it a boring thing to watch I
would say no because during that time
you can be researching the nuclear
missile that's right
that's right we knew that it would be
interesting to watch players build
nuclear missiles so let's let's reach
that you win immediately so that's just
yet another fun way it's yet another fun
way to win and I'm going to show you an
example of somebody attempting to win
that way I have it this will only take
as much time as it took me the last time
I tried to do it it's under golly you
won't have nearly oh it's right here
it's right you must be so hard to watch
me because it's like ah man he's looking
right at it let's see so let's put do
nothing bought because that's that's a
decent match for for the nuke bot where
is he is he not here he's in the middle
oh I'm looking right at him alright
alright well I mean it's it's by no
means a foregone conclusion who wins
this match this is an old version of the
code we're nuking took 1000 turns
instead of 400 turns but that's not to
say that the red team will necessarily
win on 10th turn 1000 oh wait it did
only take 400 turns wait a minute oh
that's that's 1000 and this was okay
yeah it happened there goes so so yeah
the nuke the nuclear missile has I mean
it's not a very impressive graphic it's
it's it's technically the same one we
use for every other explosion
but I think I think what we'll do is for
the finals if like one we've got a we've
got a new match visualizer so this is
this is an old version of the code
because of course I wouldn't show you
something up to date that would be that
would help you instead of hinder you and
and what we're trying to do is train you
to be amazing and and it's working I
swear uh so what I'll do is I'll show
this version of it which is great
because it shows that the thing
researching alright well later versions
of the client that you're going to
receive will show what things are
researching in the client window and I
think I think it really would not be an
excessive the pizza should be arriving
any moment so I know that the gurgling
of your stomachs is is totally
reasonable and and will be resolved
imminently if I run this version then I
think let's see is there so let's put do
nothing against the nuke guy is the nuke
guy still there he is okay so this
version of the map viewer shows
researches that are going on yeah and
you can see he's researching pickaxe
diffusion site range uh the fusion thing
that reduces the amount of energy loss
he's researching everything and whereas
the other do nothing ie you know you
could describe him as a pacifist he may
be you know the philosophy that he is
developing using three byte codes per
round may change the world so I I see no
reason to no reason to hate on to hate
on you know his choice of his choice of
vocation I would definitely not yeah no
definitely okay so you can see here that
nuke is researching so in a tournament
scenario we could all start you know
getting excited and going oh what's
going to happen is it going to be closed
and that sort of thing I mean of course
at the end it's going to be a bit of
anticlimax because I'm just going to
show a little puffball like a piece of
like somebody made popcorn on one tile
but but we will be able to overcome that
because we can just like switch to
YouTube and show a clip of you know some
giant nuclear test all right that's all
I have for you now I mean to say that
we're going to show you a whole bunch of
things you can get up and go I know a
lot of you have appointments with very
attractive young women and
and and that's totally ok but I
recommend that you stick around eat some
pizza here about how to set up battle
code and know that we will have our
developer testing code up it's a the the
team name here on the battlecode website
you can see here our team list we just
made a team that you can use to test
your code against that's down here at
the bottom and it's it's ooh it's test
test somewhere yeah two devs test there
you go
did you guys make this many teams in the
last two seconds you must have you know
it's important to multitask yeah so you
can um so you can upload your player and
test it against two devs test player and
and that'll be available all the time
and that's probably you know sort of
your first step on your road to success
thank you very much for coming and if
you have any questions you can come to
us after
you
you